max otte ist bei uns zu gast ich wollte
kurz vorstellen und vor allen dingen
erklären die augenklappe müssen sie zum
glück nur eine woche tragen sie sind am
samstag gegen eine glasscheibe glaube
ich gelaufen ist und in der woche werden
die fäden gezogen sein wie sich alles so
wie der weg gut geräte thunberg sie
haben jetzt eben die rede gehört
rhetorisch eindrucksvoll aber inhaltlich
wie würden sie es beurteilen
inhaltlich kann man schon natürlich an
der art und weise wie die klimadebatte
geführt wird das eine oder andere
kritisieren das was getan werden muss
ist völlig klar wer da was tun muss
sie steht auf dem standpunkt die
industrienationen müssen die gesamten
vorleistungen bringen auf dem standpunkt
kann man stehen
es gibt natürlich der klimadebatte viele
aspekte man kann auch überlegen ob
bevölkerungskontrolle nicht vielleicht
auch wichtig wäre weil wir einfach zu
viele sind also die debatte ist
natürlich hier sehr stark auf eine sache
zugespitzt ausstieg aus der kohle aus
den aus den energien im westen darum
dreht sich sehr vor allem das ist ein
bisschen eng aber ich kann verstehen
dass menschen sagen wir müssen anfangen
und das sagt sie auch und wir müssen
hier anfangen nur ist es natürlich nicht
ganz einfach wenn in deutschland alles
abgeschaltet wird wir beziehen dann
atomstrom weiter aus frankreich und so
weiter also da gibt es noch viele
details die hier in der tat
überdenkenswert während wenn man jetzt
die große frage auch heute abend in der
phoenix runde übrigens das große thema
wie ging klimaschutz und wirtschaftliche
zukunft hand in hand um 22.15 phoenix
runde ist das ein widerspruch oder ist
das wird das aller lang also auf lange
sicht ein 1 1 ein baum in die den
kapitalismus der zukunft ein widerspruch
ist das überhaupt nicht man kann ja
alles mögliche einbauen da haben
umweltschutz angebaut wir haben andere
dinge eingebaut die frage ist über das
wie und klaus schwab hat ja gesagt er
will dass über das forum erreichen und
über diese mechanismen und das scheint
im moment so das thema zu sagen dass die
unternehmen sich selber verpflichten das
viel corporate social responsibility und
nachhaltigkeit vorne steht das ein weg
der andere weg wären über den
gesetzgeber
das ist eigentlich der traditionelle
deutsche weg wenn wir das wirklich als
ziel erkannt haben dann würde man auch
die gesetze dementsprechend gestalten
transparent gestalten den politischen
prozess gestalten und dann würden sich
die unternehmen daran halten ich meine
deutschland hat einen großen vor
sprung in der umwelttechnik gehabt weil
wir da auch früh aktiv geworden sind
vielleicht geht es hier genauso sie
sagen gehabt haben wir den verspielten
spielen viele vorsprüngen im moment weil
wir doch insgesamt relativ
innovationsfeindlich geworden sind weil
auch viele innovationen gleich bei
fraunhofer zb von ausländischen private
equity aufgekauft werden innovationen
passiere heutzutage leider nicht mehr so
häufig in den großkonzernen sondern sehr
viel in start ups in kleineren
unternehmen und großkonzerne haben dass
so ein bisschen ich will dich sagen
komplett aber ein bisschen verlernt
selber innovativ zu sein die kaufen
lieber auf sie werden relativ mechanisch
gemanagt mindest viele also da müsste
man müsse man sich auch überlegen was
man tut und da ist klima sicherlich und
umweltschutz im allgemeinen eine gute
sache die rede von donald trump vorhin
haben sie auch aufmerksam zugeschaut wie
beurteilen sie die die war sehr spannend
ich meine es war zwei drittel eigenlob
das war zu erwarten es nochmal
marketingmann und aber was ich sehr
spannend fahren dass er also von der
arbeiterklasse gesprochen haben der
working class von der mittelschicht also
hat ganz deutlich gesagt dass zum ersten
mal unter seiner administration das
müsste man dann fakten check machen
die löhne und gehälter in der
arbeiterschicht und der mittelschicht
die ja in den letzten 20 jahren die
verlierer waren gestiegen sind und die
managergehälter nicht so stark gestiegen
sind und hat ganz klaren fokus drauf
gelegt wir müssen also für unsere arbeit
dafür unsere mittelschicht für die armen
was tun das war ja auch sein wahlkampf
thema und das andere war eben de los
tres oder der verlust von
produktionsstätten
er hat ganz sehr auf diese themen
fokussiert mit denen er den ersten
wahlkampf gewonnen hat und er hat auch
gesagt das waren die themen aus deren
grund der angetreten
das heißt es ist auch eine wahlkampfrede
gewesen am dritten november will er
wieder gewählt werden das war eine ganz
klare wahlkampfrede hat sie also
sicherlich zu drei vierteln an das
eigene publikum gerichtet aber es ging
trotzdem wichtige signale auswahl eben
drum gesagt hat so wie es die letzten 20
jahre in amerika ging geht es nicht
weiter wir müssen mehr für den arbeiter
tun wir müssen mehr für die
mittelschicht tun wir müssen die jobs
zurück holen was natürlich dann in
seiner welt
in einem bilateralismus mündet also dass
er gesagt wir machen das mit scheider
mit kanada mit mexiko das ist ja schon
eine abkehr von der multilateralen
weltordnung die wir seit 1948 46h
anerkannter und dann gab's und dann wird
timo hatten also zurück zum
bilateralismus da sehen viele natürlich
auch große gefahren